Welcome back, students,
to the pharmacology of the
antiretroviral agents.
This is the second part.
We'll talk about
the non-nucleoside
reverse transcriptase
inhibitors, the
protease inhibitors,
entry inhibitors,
and a newer one, a
more recently invented
antiretroviral drug called
the capsid inhibitor.
Let me know if
you'd like to chat.
Here are the
learning objectives
we talked about in part one.
Thanks.
Resource,
our drugs, and we'll
talk about this
group, beginning with
the non-nucleoside
reverse transcriptase
inhibitors.
Duraverine, Rilpivirine,
Afavirenz, Nivirapine,
Atravirine.
NRTIs are highly effective
in the treatment of
HIV-1 infections when
used with two NRTIs. They
have a low barrier to
resistance, side effects,
and a high potential
for drug interactions.
Again, I just put the
clinically important
characteristics of the
various drugs. In this case,
it's the Duraverine,
Efavirenz, and
Rilpivirine because these
are the ones that are
most frequently used
for initial therapy.
You don't have to remember
about the food requirement
for the test. You
should remember though
whenever you're prescribing
drugs for people that
you need to be able to
tell them how to take them.
They're all available
as a single drug so
they can be have
flexibility in what they
can be combined with,
and they also have
fixed-dose combinations
for for convenience.
Adverse effects, this is where
these drugs are
going to differ.
Duraverine is generally
well tolerated. Just
hearing about that and
knowing that it's effective,
it's going to suggest
to us, ah, it looks
like that might be a
preferred drug, and it is.
It is a CYP3A4 substrate, and
that's the major mechanism
of drug interactions with
that, with teravirine.
I'm going to jump over
here to rapivirine.
It's combined with
tenofavir and M-tricytamine,
generally well-tolerated.
It can have some
neuropsychiatric effects and
QT interval prolongation.
CYP3A4 again, and it needs
to have an acid stomach.
Now efavirenz. This is older
compared to the other two.
Again, it's combined
in one pill.
Efavirenz is really well
known for its neuropsychiatric
side effects. Dizziness,
abnormal dreams, depression,
insomnia, can also cause
headache, skin rash,
and here we have our QT
interval prolongation again.
It is a mixed inducer
and inhibitor. It
both inhibits and
induces various CYPs,
as well as being a
substrate of CYP3A4.
And those are the
takeaway messages for
the three drugs. Now
I want to draw your
attention again to
Rilpivirine here.
Treatment naive adults
with HIV RNA less than 100
,000 copies per milliliter
and a CD4 count of at
least 200 cells per cubic
millimeter. And the reason
for this requirement is
that in individuals who
have a greater viral load,
there is reduced efficacy,
a risk of virologic
failure in these patients.
Recall that rilpivirine
is combined with
cabotegravir for that
two-drug combination.
They are noncompetitive
inhibitors. They bind
to an allosteric site on
reverse transcriptase,
and they are just
chemicals, so they don't
require activation
by cellular enzymes.
They do induce a
conformational change by
binding to that
allosteric site, and that
will decrease the
activity of the enzyme.
This structure, this
protein structure here,
has been likened to a hand.
So here we have our NNRTI,
here we have our active site.
The NNRTI allosteric
site is in the so-called
palm domain. So if you read
that in the literature,
you'll understand what
they're talking about.
Resistance,
resistance, resistance.
Single amino acid changes
in the binding pocket
confers high-level
drug resistance. High
-level cross-resistance
occurs within the class.
This is general statements.
Transmitted resistance,
so that's person-to-person
transmission of HIV that
has resistance to the NNRTIs
is more common than with
the entities in the ***. So
what's the recommendation?
Resistance testing
should be performed
before the initiation
of an NNRTI in a
patient who has not
been treated before.
Rashes, this is a class
effect. They occur
frequently with the
NNRTIs, usually during
the first four weeks,
and GI effects.
Drug interactions,
obviously there's high
potential. You've learned
a lot about mechanisms
of drug interactions
up to this point.
Oh, let me just, this is one
that they like on the boards,
the efavirenz
-methadone interaction.
Induction of the CYP2B6
and 3A4, which are drug
metabolizers of methadone,
can decrease methadone levels
and that can and lead to
opioid withdrawal symptoms.
Now, Nevirapine and
Atravirine, I did
put stars on them
because there are
some important
things to know about
them and also it's
highly likely these
information would
appear on the boards.
So Nevirapine has
really a very low
barrier to resistance
and is not recommended
for initial
antiretroviral therapy.
It is mainly used
for presumptive
therapy in neonates
at high risk for HIV,
and it is used in a
combination that is known
to be effective and safe
for the brand-new baby,
cydovidine, amtricitabine,
and nivirapine.
this is an interesting
feature also they love it on
the boards if european
should not be used in females
with cd4 count of greater
than 250 cells per cubic
millimeter or in males of 400
cells greater than 400 cells
per cubic millimeter because
of when it was done so
There is an association
with an increased risk
of severe life-threatening
fatal hepatotoxicity,
which is an adverse
effect of nivirapine.
So this is a
takeaway, not only for
here, yes, you should
know it for here,
you should also know
it for the boards.
A travarine, the
takeaway message here,
is that it has a
higher barrier to
resistance than the
others in the group.
and it is an option for the
treatment experienced patient,
assuming, of course, that the
drug is going to be effective.
It seems to have reduced
toxicity compared
to efavirenz, but
it can cause rash.
And we have our
drug interactions.
So those are the takeaway
messages with those two drugs.
This is a picture of
the efavirenz rash,
Easy to see on this
light-skinned person.
And some review questions.
What are the important
clinically relevant takeaways
about the pharmacokinetic
properties of the NNRTIs
class? How is viral resistance
related to the NNRTI's
mechanism of action? What
criteria must be met before
Rilpivirine is administered
to the ART-naive patient?
What are the class and
drug-specific toxicities
to remember? and which
patients are at highest
risk for nivirapine-related
hepatotoxicity. I'll
give you a moment if you
wish to pause your video.
The answers, they are
oral, extensive protein
binding, extensive hepatic
metabolism by CYPs,
drug and metabolites
excreted in urine
feces, and once
-daily dosing. An
advantage, oral and
once-daily dosing.
Single mutations in
reverse transcriptase
drug-binding site confers high
-level resistance and
cross-resistance.
Etrevirine has a higher
barrier to resistance
compared to the others, and
it is used for treatment
-experienced patients,
assuming it's effective.
In ART-naive patients
with a viral load of
greater than 100,000
copies per milliliter and
CD4 count of less than
200 cells per cubic
millimeter should not be
initiated on rilpivirine
due to increased risk
of virologic failure.
And rash, GI, discomfort
are class adverse effects.
Efavirins and rilpivirin
can cause some
neuropsychiatric
effects, especially
efavirins, and QT
interval prolongation.
Duraverine has some
neuropsychiatric
effects, much less.
Niverapine, hepatotoxicity,
and discontinue
NNRTI at the first
sign of rash.
Females with a CD4 count
of greater than 250 cells
per cubic millimeter and
males with a CD count
of greater than 400 cells
per cubic millimeter,
are at highest risk for
nevirapine-related
hepatotoxicity.
Which brings us to our
protease inhibitors, and
really there are only two
that are used currently.
At the bottom of the
slide I've indicated
the others that are
no longer used for
art-naive patients
because of lower efficacy,
greater pill burden,
or increased toxicity.
Adizanavir and
durunivir both must be
boosted with a
pharmacokinetic enhancer.
PI-based regimens have
demonstrated virologic
potency, durability in
treatment-naive patients,
and a high barrier to
resistance. But they have
numerous side effects
and drug interactions.
So let's talk about our
pharmacokinetic boosting
concept that I've mentioned
a number of times.
Ritonavir was originally
developed as a
protease inhibitor
for therapeutic use.
It was found because
of its very strong
inhibition of CYP3A4,
even at low doses, that
it is useful as a
pharmacokinetic enhancer.
And cobecostat came
along much later. It
has no antiviral ability
at all. It's just
a CYP3A4 inhibitor.
and both of these
are inhibitors of p
-glycoprotein as well.
So what's the point?
Well, if we inhibit CYP3A4,
we therefore increase
the amount of drug
that actually gets
into the bloodstream,
and we reduce the rate at
which it is eliminated.
So we get this curve
that looks like this
instead of this curve
that looks like that.
In summary, using
a pharmacokinetic
enhancer increases
plasma concentrations,
increases duration of
action, and improves
the efficacy of the
protease inhibitor.
Now for the characteristics
of the protease inhibitors.
boosted out of xanavir,
boosted darunavir. You see
they are boosted either with
cabecostat or ritonavir.
They should be given
with food. I'm not going
to be asking this on
an exam. It's important
for you as prescribers
to know how to
counsel your patients on
how to take the drugs.
Both drugs are very convenient
wants a daily dosing
for the individual who has
not had antiretroviral therapy
twice daily for the treatment
experienced patient.
They are in fixed
dose combination
with cobecostat, both of them,
and arunivir is also in
combination with tenofavir
alafenamide and m
-tricitabine. Very convenient.
Adizanavir, cobecostat,
will need to be taken
with another pill, probably
a two-pill regimen.
Adverse effects, class effects.
These are common, nausea,
vomiting, diarrhea,
cardiac conduction
abnormalities can occur,
glucose and lipid
metabolism, problems
with Cushingoid fat
redistribution. That
would be the buffalo
hump, the round face,
the slender arms and legs
with the protuberant belly,
increased LDL cholesterol,
increased triglycerides,
hyperglycemia, and
insulin resistance.
Patients need to be
informed about these
and it's important
to monitor for them.
They may need to
be treated for the
adverse effects
with other drugs.
Drug-specific
adverse effects now,
adizanavir can cause
hyperbilirubinemia and jaundice.
This is not harmful, but
patients can be concerned
about the yellowish-looking
color of their skin.
Also, gallstones, kidney
stones, kidney injury.
With regard to darunivir,
skin rash, which can be
severe, and patients who
have a history of sulfonamide
allergy should be
avoiding this drug because
darunivir has a sulfonamide
moiety in its structure.
It can cause increase in serum
transaminases, which
need to be watched.
Liver toxicity has
occurred, including severe
liver toxicity,
hepatitis. The drug is
contraindicated in
individuals with severe liver
disease, as you could
yourselves anticipate.
CYP3A4 drug-drug
interactions, obviously.
Protease inhibitors
themselves are inhibitors
of CYP3A4, in addition
to the covicostat
and ritonavir, which
are strong inhibitors.
CYP, moving now to the
other significant drug
-drug interactions,
adizanivir needs to be taken
on an acid stomach for
optimal absorption.
Darunivir doesn't
matter so much.
How do they work?
Here's the structure of a drug.
Here is the enzyme.
Here is the active side
of the enzyme, and very
simply, the drug is a
reversible inhibitor of
protease that prevents
the proteolytic cleavage
of this large polyprotein
called the GAG and GAG
-POL proteins. And as
a result, this large
polyprotein is not cleaved
into the active enzymes
that the HIV needs for
functioning and structure.
And as a result,
immature virions
are released out of the cells.
Resistance, it
requires multiple
point mutations
in the Paul gene.
Transmitted resistance
is uncommon.
This means that if you
have a patient who really
needs to get started on
antiretroviral therapy quickly,
It can be done with a
protease inhibitor before
receiving the resistance
information from the lab.
Cross resistance is
variable, so that's a matter
of looking up to see what's
going to be cross resistant.
And the treatment
-experienced individual, that
should really be handled
by an individual, a
practitioner, who is well
-experienced in HIV therapy.
Potential drug
interactions with
CYP3A4 inhibition,
that's obvious.
There are many, many,
many. I've given you two
examples here. Statins. So
why statins? Well, people
can develop this
metabolic problem, this
dyslipidemia, and how do
we treat that with statins?
So, inhibition of
CYP3A4 with statins that
are substrates of
CYP3A4, which are common,
can cause increases in
the concentrations in the
blood if the drug gets
carried to the skeletal
muscles, which can result
in muscle toxicity,
skeletal muscle
toxicity, including
severe muscle toxicity
rhabdomyolysis,
which in turn can cause
acute kidney injury.
Midazolam is another one that's
frequently listed in
with among *** because
of its narrow
therapeutic window.
And on top of it, we
have P-glycoprotein
inhibition, which
can, which goes along
really with the two
CYP3A4 P-glycoprotein.
With regard to P
-glycoprotein, digoxin is
frequently mentioned
because it has a narrow
substrate, it requires
P-glycoprotein.
I should say it's a
substrate of p-glycoprotein,
and as a result, it gets
pumped out of the intestine,
et cetera, et cetera.
Now, if we're blocking it,
p-glycoprotein, then more
of the digoxin can be
absorbed, which can increase
the risk of digoxin toxicity,
along with the other sites
of p-glycoprotein inhibition
in the body. With regard
to hormonal contraception,
the proposed mechanism
is by induction of UDP
-glucuronal transferase,
biritonavir, and the PI itself.
So increasing the rate of
metabolism of the hormone,
estrogen, will decrease the
efficacy of the hormonal
contraception. And regarding
a methadone, methadone
levels are decreased, which
can induce opioid withdrawal
syndrome, but that mechanism
hasn't been identified.
So some questions now.
What are the most commonly
used *** in ART for initial
therapy? What is the
rationale for concomitant
administration of ritonavir or
cabecostat? And my mind's
ear, I can hear you answering
these questions right
off the top of your head.
What adverse effects are
associated with the pi's
class? And I invite you
to pause the computer and
see if you can think of
it just yourself. And
then if you want, you can
look back at the answers.
Boosted adesanivir,
boosted durunivir,
which have demonstrated
virologic potency,
durability in treatment,
naïve patients, and
high barrier to
resistance. In addition,
from among the ***, they tend
to be quite well tolerated.
concomitant administration
of rotonavir and kubicostat
to inhibit CYP3A4 in
order to increase plasma
concentration of the
partner protease inhibitor,
which will increase the
duration of action and improve
the efficacy of the
partner protease inhibitor.
Class adverse effects,
nausea, vomiting, diarrhea,
which are quite common,
cardiac conduction
abnormalities, disturbances
in glucose and lipid
metabolism with hyperlipidemia,
hypertriglyceridemia,
Cushingoid fat redistribution,
hyperglycemia, and
insulin resistance.
In addition to the
drug-specific effects,
ATV can cause
hyperbilirubinemia,
jaundice, gall and
kidney stones, and
Derenavir can cause
rash and liver toxicity.
Now, we're moving on to
the entry inhibitors,
Miravirac and Fuvertide,
Fostemsevir and Ibalizumab.
This illustration here
shows our white blood cells,
shows HIV docking, T
-cell receptor, CCR5,
CXCR4, so the cytokine
receptors that are
co-receptors that are
necessary for fusion.
So we'll begin with Meravirox,
CCR5 inhibitor, activity
against HIV-1, but only
CCR5-tropic strains, the
ones that are expressing
CCR5, but not CXCR4. This
figure shows our cytokine
receptors here, and our HIV,
and this little
thing is showing our
Meraviroc here,
blocking this effect.
The Mirabaroc is oral,
bioavailability is
pretty low, but they've
dosed it so that it
achieves adequate plasma
concentrations. Here's
our CYP3A4 again. Goes out
through the feces and
the urine, both routes,
half-life 14 to 18 hours,
not really long
enough for once daily
dosing, so it's
dosed twice a day.
Blocks the binding
of the HIV outer
envelope protein
GP120 to the CCR5
chemokine receptor,
cytokine receptor.
Talked about the
activity resistance shift
in tropism to CXCR4 or
HIV that is expressing
both CCR5 and CXCR4.
Because then the virus
can connect, can co
-recept with the CXCR4.
And here are some
more mutations.
You don't have to
memorize those.
This is the main
one to remember.
So what do we do about
this? Prior to therapy,
tropism testing should be
performed for the presence
of the CXCR5 protropic
HIV1 infection. If CXCR4 is
expressed, then Miraviroc
will not be effective.
Here's the use, obviously.
Hepatotoxicity, which can be
preceded by severe rash and or,
evidence a systemic
allergic reaction.
It's very serious,
and the obvious drug
interactions that we've
talked about many times.
Now the fusion
inhibitor and FUVR Tide.
This is a structure,
it's actually a protein.
So this is a protein.
That's what it is.
And you see a big
protein like that?
Are we going to take
it ******? No. It
has to be injected.
And this figure we're showing
the mechanism of action.
We have the binding
of this GP120 and
the GP41 coming down
to cause the fusion.
and this is where
our infuvertide
will block that fusion effect.
So chemistry, I am giving
you the chemistry on
this one. Synthetic peptide,
36 amino acids, derived
from a part of the
transmembrane GP41 protein
of HIV-1 involved in the
fusion. So it will bind
to that spot, but it
will inhibit the fusion.
Subcutaneously
metabolized by proteolytic
hydrolysis, of course,
it's a protein.
It's got a pretty
short half-life.
So, twice daily sub-Q dosing.
Mechanism binds HIV-1
envelope protein GP41,
One, inhibits the
conformational change required
for fusion and therefore
inhibits fusion.
Resistance, mutations in the
codon, well the binding site.
What do we use it for?
Treatment experienced patients.
Adverse effects, the main
one is ejection site.
It can be painful, erythema,
enduration, nodules,
and that twice daily
dosing makes long-term
use within fever time
kind of difficult.
Drug interactions.
Well, no known metabolic
drug interactions.
That's something.
Now, Fostempsevir is a
more recently developed
fusion inhibitor
against HIV-1. It binds
CD4 binding site and
prevents the GP120
conformational change
required for attachment.
So infuvertitis GP41,
Temsevir is actually the
active form, Fos-Temsevir
is a prodrug, that
blocks CD4 binding site.
Pro-drug oral
hydrolysis to Tempsevir,
here's CYP3A4 and p
-glycoprotein again,
so high potential for
drug interactions.
Strong CYP3A4 inducers
should be avoided. You
can think of that as a
contraindication. Mechanism
of action, HIV-1, GP
-120 envelope adjacent to
the GP-120 CD4 binding
site prevents GP-120
conformational change,
which prevents attachment.
Treatment of HIV-1 heavily
treatment experienced adults.
Nausea is the most common.
in elevation and hepatic
enzymes, especially
in people who have
hepatitis virus.
QT interval prolongation.
Excuse me for this music.
And strong CYP3A4 induces
are contraindicated.
As I said here, it's
worth repeating.
Second nature to you now. You
don't have to memorize it.
And now here's
Ibalizumab, it's a
monoclonal antibody
as you can tell from
the name, post
-attachment inhibitor.
It blocks something
called domain two
and it interferes with the post
-attachment steps. Here we have,
it indicated here,
it looks like domain two,
the second bubble, second
ball. on CD4 interferes
with post-attachment
steps required for HIV
entry into the host cell.
Heavily treatment experienced
individuals again.
And capsid inhibitor
lenocapivir
of this group,
the most recently
developed one,
came out in 2022.
Here we have the capsid.
right in here, and this
figure shows what's happening
with the capsid internally,
intracellularly.
Lenacapavir directly
binds the interface
between capsid protein,
which is called P24,
subunits in hexamers,
and that changes its
conformation, which
stabilizes it because it
needs to be coming apart,
as you can see here.
And that will prevent viral
uncoating and disrupts
the viral life cycle.
It inhibits HIV-1
replication by blocking
capsid-mediated nuclear uptake
so it doesn't get into
the nucleus. It blocks
viral assembly and release
by interfering with
this gag-gag-pole function,
which is necessary
for cleaving off the
effective active proteins.
And it blocks the
capsid core formation
by disrupting the
rate of capsid subunit
association. So it
acts at multiple steps.
Sub-Q maintenance, so we have
another injectable on board.
Start out with oral initiation.
CYP3A4 is involved
in its really
complex hepatic metabolism,
and other CYPs and other
metabolic enzymes. It
goes out as unchanged
drug and metabolites
through the feces, and
it's got a half-life of
up to 12 days for the
oral, which is an oral
kind of lead-in, and the
sub-Q, 8 to 12 weeks.
So, it is given for
maintenance once every
six months after
this initial lead-in,
which I'm not going to
ask you to remember.
heavily treatment experienced
adults combination with
other antivirals generally
well tolerated that's a
good thing injection site
reactions reported and
don't use it with CYP3A4
inducers you see the pattern
it's just running the thread
is running through all
of these different drugs you
learn it once and and you
can just draw lines to it
from all of these drugs.
And let's just talk
for a few minutes
about the treatment guidelines.
ART is recommended for
all people living with HIV
to improve their health
and reduce the risk of
HIV transmission to HIV
-uninfected *** partners.
This basic principle
carries through all of
the different populations
that we'll see.
Two NRTIs plus an
INSTi carries through
all of the populations
except for neonates.
Alternatives and then
on the RTI or a boosted
PI we saw that we saw
those drugs that are
preferred to Abacavir
and M-tricitabine is in a
number of fixed-dose
combinations, both TDF and
TAF with M-tricitabine,
which were discovered and
manufactured by the
same drug company, so it
makes sense that those
two are combined a lot.
Abacavir and lamivudine, we
have to remember whenever
abacavir is used, HLA-B
star 5701 screening prior
to therapy, and resistance
testing should be a guide
to selection of an antiviral
regimen in both treatment
-naive and treatment
-experienced patients because
transfer of resistance genes.
So that's called
transmitted drug resistance.
Two drug regimens, I've
listed them out here. We
talked about the dolotegravir,
rapivirine, so you do
need to remember that one.
but I've included several
others here and the
requirements are the same. There
is one. This one is for
treatment naive patients
with no known or suspected
resistance to individual
components of the drug and
certain other criteria.
So please remember this one.
Treatment experienced
patients, well, that's a lot
more challenging. These people
should be referred to an
infectious disease expert
in this treatment of HIV.
Resistance testing naturally.
Goals of treatment.
The same as the original goal.
Maximal virologic suppression.
If possible. Sometimes
it's not possible.
then the idea is just
to halt the progression.
Try and use three active
drugs if possible.
Importantly, why is the
patient treatment experienced?
Has the patient been sticking
to the therapy up till now?
Find out what the
barriers to adherence are
and try and address
them with the patient.
All of this should be a
conversation, everything
should be a conversation
with the patient
and the patient should
be agreeing to therapy.
Pre-exposure prophylaxis,
tenofovir M
-tricitabine, tenofovir M
-tricitabine, tenofovir
M-tricitabine. either
TDF or TAF with m
-tricytamine, those two.
These are for HIV
-negative individuals.
They need to stick
to the therapy. They
need to agree to
stick to the therapy.
And it's part of a
comprehensive prevention
strategy involving the
drugs and behaviors.
Also on the scene now is
cabotegravir intramuscular
intramuscular and to
the gluteal muscle
every two months. This
is actually adolescents
now and adults. It's
gotten another indication.
Post-exposure prophylaxis
for individuals
who, this is called
a needle stick,
who are at risk of acquiring
HIV from a needle stick.
Preferred, here we go again,
TDF-M-tricitabine
with dolotegravir.
Ralotegravir is also
recommended for this purpose.
And we have our alternative
with our boosted PI.
Four-week duration, start
as soon as possible.
And consult a physician
experienced in
this domain. follow
-up counseling, post
-exposure testing,
medical evaluation.
So it's a whole group
of things to do.
Transgender people.
Recommended for all
transgender people living with
HIV like all people living
with HIV to improve their
health and reduce the
risk of HIV transmission.
HIV care services
should be provided. Now
there's a wrinkle
here, and that is the
drugs that are being
used in the gender
-affirming transition,
the hormone therapies.
So these can cause
adverse effects, they
can cause drug
interactions, so need to be
considered when
treating transgender
people with HIV with
antiretroviral therapy.
women with HIV these are
women who are assigned female
at birth they're not pregnant
they are using hormonal
contraceptives drugs we
need to be thinking about
drug interactions pregnant
people the goal with anyone
who's pregnant is to
maintain a viral load below
the limit of detection
throughout out the pregnancy to
reduce transmission to the
fetus and to the newborn.
All HIV-infected pregnant
people should receive
a combination antepartum
during pregnancy antiviral
therapy regardless of
CD4 counter HIV RNA
copy number. They should
be getting the therapy.
So what do we use?
Well, obviously drugs
that are effective
and safe in the
pregnant person and
safe for the fetus.
So drugs where there's
extensive experience,
where this data has
accumulated over
many years, should
be well tolerated,
good short-term safety profile,
pharmacokinetics that are not
significantly altered
during pregnancy as
the fetus grows and
grows and grows.
high placental transfer
to the fetus because after
all besides the health of
the mother the intention is
to reduce transmission and
of course no evidence of
teratogenicity preferred
ah here it is again 2 nrti
backbone plus Stolotegravir,
that is the preferred.
Some alternates, Bic
-Tegravir, Raltegravir,
or a PI, boosted adizanavir,
or NNRTI if avarens
or rilpivirine.
So I hear some of
you saying, no, if
avarens is known
to be teratogenic,
well over all of
these years, there
has been good evidence
to show so that
it is indeed safe
in early pregnancy.
Prevention of
intrapartum mother-to
-child transmission.
So this is actually
during the labor
and delivery stage.
Zydovidine IV by
continuous infusion during
labor if the patient
has a viral load
or an unknown viral
load near delivery.
We do not need to use
it in patients who
have been sticking to
their antiretroviral
therapy throughout
their pregnancy.
They have a low viral
load late in pregnancy
because at this point
there isn't a concern
about transfer to the
fetus, to the newborn.
For individuals with
unknown HIV status,
there isn't rapid
HIV screening,
confirmatory testing
if that's positive.
Initiate mother and
infant on HIV drugs
pending the results,
and if negative,
the therapy can be stopped.
So what about the newborn?
Well, that's based on risk,
and that risk is based on
the mother's viral load
within the four weeks of
delivery. So low-risk,
as well as zidovudine
for four weeks, and the
newborn infant who is 37
weeks gestation or more.
Infants who do not
meet this criteria,
then they can get
the zidovudine for a
longer period of
time, same or longer.
Now high-risk, presumptive
antiretroviral therapy
from birth for two
to six weeks. by that
time, it can be determined
if the baby has HIV.
So let's use zidovidine,
m-tricitabine, and
nevirapine. I mentioned
that one earlier.
And an alternative,
well, also preferred,
zidovidine, m-tricitabine,
and raltegravir.
So those are two arts,
two therapy regimens
for the newborn at
high risk for HIV.
Pediatric patients,
it's the same
concept, two NRTIs
and an INSTI.
Remembering that
adherence can be hard
for children, and
children are growing,
and that can affect the
dosing of the HIV therapy.
Not recommended for children.
efavirins-based,
etravirin-based,
maravirac-based,
cabotegravir, and drugs
that have a low efficacy,
or there's just not enough
information on them.
I've also put breastfeeding
on this slide,
so you can remember to
think about the mothers
who wish to breastfeed.
If they have acute or
primary HIV, they
shouldn't be breastfeeding.
There is no consensus on the
appropriate management of
antiretroviral prophylaxis
for infants of individuals
with sustained viral
suppression who are breastfed.
So we just don't know.
Treatment of the
older patient. Now the
concerns here are
about comorbidities and
other drugs, so drug
-drug interactions,
neurocognitive function,
whether or not the patient
has access to medical
and social services.
I'm not going to read
this to you. These
are drug regimens that
should not be used.
These, as you can see, are
the older drugs in here,
and these are relevant,
number one, for pharmacology
concepts, but also these could
still appear on board exams
even though the drugs are
not widely used anymore.
And here's some more,
and I'm not going
to read you the summary,
it's just covering
everything we talked
about in part two.
So thank you very much for
listening to this lecture.